et pour en parler nous sommes avec
philippe bélair secrétaire général cgt
santé guadeloupe bonsoir merci d'être
avec nous ce conflit social qui avons
déclenché par une opposition à la
vaccination obligatoire un des soignants
et opaque sanitaires on l'a dit le cache
évidemment également une défiance à
l'égard de la politique menée par le
gouvernement comment l'expliquer
on expliquer quoi exactement
est-ce que c'est l'entêtement du
gouvernement où notre détermination
en ce qu'il s'agit véritablement
depuis le mois de juillet le 17 juillet
exactement une nous sommes en train de
marcher d'expliquer à la population de
faire en sorte que non seulement la
population mais aussi aux responsables
politiques puissent entendre vos
horizons au non sens des mesures
sanitaires qui sont prises et aucun
retour n'est fait nous écrivons nous
faisons des propositions en expliquant
la situation nous expliquant que cette
loi ne peut pas être applicable six
mille îles déjà
handicapé pendant certain nombre de
réformes hospitalières et une
restructuration de l'offre sanitaire qui
qui nous a pénalisés énormément jusqu'à
ce jour le gouvernement est dans une
logique
implacable dans ses bottes et il veut
appliquer vaille que vaille sa loi de 5
août dernier voilà la situation le
problème c'est qu'en face il ya une
population se ne s'est pas seulement ça
a commencé avec les soignants et
maintenant toute la population mobilisé
et très très mobilisé même si des
tentatives de renversement du pkk sont
tentées mais ça ne marche pas ça ne
mange pas population est entièrement
à nuuk où
quand vous dites cette fois elle peut
pas s'appliquer en guadeloupe sur l'île
c'est vrai que le gouvernement veut
simplement peut être appliqué la loi
française la guadeloupe fait partie
intégrante de la france est une forme de
principe d'égalité qu'est-ce que vous
pouvez y est pour y répondre à cet
argument
j'entends bien madame le seul problème
c'est que lorsqu'il a fallu imposer le
comic-con envoie de l'eau on affine
dérogation donc je m'étonne pour me
saute c'est un argument aujourd'hui
s'il ya eu dérogation pour nous
empoisonner je vois pas pourquoi il peut
avoir une dérogation parce que ce soit
comme une demande devront ce n'est pas
l'absence de vaccination concernant ce
que d'autres tentent de vouloir dire à
notre place non nous sommes pas anti
anti vaccin puisque nous sommes des
choix bien ce serait un comble d'être
anti mac si tous les soirs seulement
nous estimons avec tous les standards
qualité je vais déjà dit je le répète
tous les sens à sa vie qui ont eu lieu
intérieurement nous choisit aujourd'hui
que maintenant il y en a marre
aujourd'hui s'ils n'appartiennent plus à
paris de nous dire ce qui est bon pour
vous au regard de ce que nous voyons au
poids de nouveau à côté il y à des
traitements qui marche il y a les
vaccins conventionnel qui existe et je
ne vois pas pourquoi on veut lui imposer
d'ailleurs je me dis que la loi parle d'
obligations vaccinales ont l'obligation
dé s'incliner d'accord or le syli à une
éducation pas eu d'accident
parallèlement le gouvernement japonais
les essais cliniques les produits en à m
donc il y a quand même dans dans leur
comportement
les options ouvertes il ya quand même
d'une enfance pour vous c'est une
question peut-être au-delà des mots tout
simplement de confiance brisé et ce
depuis plusieurs années depuis le
scandale des pesticides dans les années
70 80
il y a eu
la confiance est brisée c'est vrai mais
ce n'est pas seulement une affaire de
mou de sémantique c'est très important
on se peut il ya beaucoup de confusion
qui sont faites pour pouvoir dénaturer
notre mouvement nous sommes en une fois
anti-vaccins je le répète je tiens à le
souligner pas si petit que ça doit être
clair c'est un mouvement où on
revendique au regard de ce qui s'est
passé par le passé revendique d'avoir le
lot a deux choix de ce qu'on peut nous
donner par ailleurs il faut que je vous
explique que nous on ne panique pas un
terme par rapport à la pandémie pas pour
vivre ce pourquoi parce que nous avons
l'habitude nous avons l'habitude des
pandémies nous avons l'habitude kg
vicieuse karachi qu'il ya ding grippe
etc nous avons cette habitude
s'est pas vraiment comme les gages on ne
peut pas les faire chier avec ça on peut
pas nous faire peur avec ça la mesure où
nous avons jugé en vidéo parce qu'une
tradition épidémique donc si notre
revendication est légitime c'est bien
parce qu'en fait nous sommes bien placés
pour aaa à une épidémie ou pandémie nous
sommes bien placés mais ça c'est bon ça
c'est pas bon le ministre d outre-mer à
sébastien lecornu a confirmé qu'il se
rendrait prochainement en guadeloupe et
en martinique
une fois que l'ordre sera rétabli il
arrive un peu tard vous auriez peut-être
aimé le voir avant
il arrive non seulement un peu tard mais
voit pas ce qu'on pouvait faire prêter
serment
la seule chose qui ait pour tous nous
parce qu'il faut être clair nous sommes
déterminés
secret seule et unique chose qui doit
être clair c'est que
qu'il vienne lui ou qu'il envoie une
mission quelconque nous demandons une
négociation
cette négociation repose sur nos
revendications qui sont très très clairs
voilà donc qu'ils viennent je ne sais
pas je sais pas ce qu'est ce qu'ils
savent ce que ça va donner toujours est
il que
aujourd'hui je crois c'est lui même que
c'est lui même c'est notre ministre
opposés
je dis à régir la vaccination etc le
nouveau plan par rapport à horgues et de
10 dans l'hexagone si si leur opposition
était un peu écoutés je pense que
l'organisation sanitaire par rapport à
cette aune des vivres eau a été tout
autre et je pense que nous serions pas à
ce niveau là peau je le répète et je les
dis souvent aux antennes dernier en
masse pour nous c'est une gestion
idéologie que ça des familles gestion
syndiqués merci beaucoup d'avoir été
avec nous en direct sur rt france
monsieur baylet remercie à vous